elkezdtem intenzíven tanulmányozni hogy
hogyan lehet ezt produktivitásra
használni hogyan tudok egy jobb
menedzserré válni hogyan tudok egy jobb
cégvezetővé válni hogyan tudok egy jobb
családapává is válni akár azáltal hogy
ezt az ai chatbotot használom ami
például a a chat gpt is a célom az hogy
olyan alapokat tudjak megosztani olyan
kincseket amik amelyeket szinte nap mint
nap használok másokkal is amelyek
általános érvényűek amelyeket nem csak a
chat gpt-nél használni hanem a geminál
grocknál és más hasonló chatbotoknál is
lehet használni én azt tapasztaltam
személyesen hogy körülbelül legalább
háromszor produktívabbá váltam a a a
szakmai életemben és nem csak a szakmai
életemben